- Good morning, everyone.
As builders, and as humans,
we know clocks are important.
Today we're gonna cover why,
why they're important,
and how they're good
in the systems and
technologies that we build.
This is CMP409,
"It's About Time! Improving
Distributed Systems
with Amazon Times Sync."
My name is Josh Levinson.
I'm a principal product manager for EC2.
I'm joined by Julien Ridoux,
who's a principal software engineer,
and Nikolai Larbalestier,
who's a senior vice president
of Cloud Strategy and Enterprise
Architecture at Nasdaq.
Today we're gonna go
very deep into clocks,
making a clock,
what is a good clock?
Leveraging and using a good clock,
and then using good clocks
globally at planetary scale
on AWS.
I wanna remind you that
this is a 400-level talk.
You do not need to understand the concepts
we're gonna go through at the
start of this presentation.
Towards the end, we're gonna
share how we simplify things,
and we've done the heavy lifting for you
so you could take advantage
of this in your systems,
or using AWS partners systems
to use these definitely tricky
concepts in your workloads.
I like starting with a quote,
and this one from Barbara Liskov.
"Synchronized clocks are interesting
because they can be used
to improve the performance
of a distributed system
by reducing communication."
We're going to get back to this,
how clocks reduce communication,
and how clocks make systems more simple
when you take advantage of them.
Starting just with a baseline
before we get into what a clock is,
is what clocks are used for.
I think we all understand
clocks as a common scale of measurement,
and historically distributed systems
have not been built to trust clocks.
Clocks are used for human observability.
That's log messages, metrics monitoring,
UI dashboards.
We think of sports,
how much time is left in a period,
or how much time it took
for someone to run a race.
Auditing, another place that I think
we're all familiar with clocks,
in industries like financial
services, healthcare,
broadcast media, online gaming,
making sure events happen
synchronously at the same time.
And in the last quadrant,
I have distributed systems
with a question mark.
Again, going back to that
quote from, from Barbara Liskov
where, if you have a reliable clock,
you can simplify your systems,
reduce locking, leader election,
reduce those communications,
and we're gonna answer the
how in this presentation.
To start off, I like to talk
about just what is a clock.
Julien, could you share what is a clock?
- I will try my best.
Thank you, Josh.
So the beginning of this journey,
we really wanted to start
with some of the basics,
which is how to build a computer clock.
And at this level, you
really need two things,
very simple things.
One thing that ticks periodically,
and one thing that counts
this number of cycles.
Usually this is a piece of hardware
that is combining these two functions.
But again, something that
ticks, something that counts.
If you have this information,
you can then build a clock,
and that's represented by the equation
at the bottom of this slide.
At the perfect time, T, you
could read the clock C here
by saying that this is the
number of cycles that it laps
divided by the frequency,
and some constant.
Sounds a little bit esoteric.
Lemme make it simpler.
Imagine that you have
counted 1,000 cycles,
and you know that your hardware
is doing one cycle per second.
Well, 1,000 cycles, one second each,
1,000 seconds have elapsed.
You have now built a clock.
This is the fundamental component
that allow you to build
a clock on the computer.
Alright, I just talk about some hardware.
What does that look like?
You have a range of options.
From the left-hand side
here to the right-hand side,
it ranges from small form
factor crystal oscillators
to equipment that you will
find in the physics lab.
Cesium beams, hydrogen masers,
and optical clock soon to be released.
In terms of form factor, you
range from a few millimeters
to things that are pieces of equipment
that are size of a cabinet.
Even this ones are a bit more difficult
to fit into a computer.
And of course the price
point changes as well.
On the left-hand side
it tends to be a better price
point for cloud computing.
On the right-hand side,
this can range from hundreds
of thousands of dollars
if you want to buy this
piece of equipment.
So we have trade offs in
terms of small form factor
or not in terms of price points,
but also in terms of the quality
of the hardware you can
purchase to build a clock.
The ability for hardware
to keep accuracy within one microsecond
changes along that scale.
On the left-hand side,
you can hold one microsecond accuracy
for about a couple of seconds.
On the right-hand side,
when you go to hydrogen
masers and optical clock,
you can keep accuracy for
years, if not centuries,
on watch that promise.
So the other range of hardware
that you can choose from
to be the clock in the computer.
But no matter what decision you make,
all oscillators drift,
even the most accurate
atomic clock do drift,
just that it'll take them centuries
for you to observe that
drift at a microsecond level.
In general, we tend to
have a small form factor,
a good price point,
and these oscillators that drift
due to manufacturing process or aging,
these are mostly considerations
that are of importance for physicists.
For us, cloud providers
building computers,
we mostly care about small differences
in power supply or temperature variations
due to the impact of your workload
on your processor CPUs,
and the server as a whole.
So I did lie a little
in my previous slide.
I gave you an equation that
say you can build a clock
if you know the number of cycles
and you know how long each cycle is.
But the truth is that the
frequency of this cycle
does change over time,
as is shown in this equation.
And the net result is that clocks drift.
And we are showing you an example in here
with this graph.
Here we picked an EC2 instance
that's been running for about five days,
and we let the oscillator free running,
no correction applied.
What you see is that over
a period of five days,
the clock has been drifting
by about 75 millisecond,
which is something you would expect.
Alright, so we have the hardware
in order to build a clock.
We've observed that the
hardware does drift over time.
What can we do about this?
Well we need to track and
correct for that drift.
How does that work?
Well, computers are no
different than us humans.
Imagine you have a wristwatch,
and that watch is not on time.
You will ask a friend, Josh, for example,
asking what time it is.
Josh give you the answer.
You can adjust your
watch, you're good to go.
Computers are no different.
Here we're representing a small example
that is illustrate the
network time protocol
that has been used for decades now.
Effectively you have a clock,
that's the bottom line on this graph
that needs to be adjusted.
The top line is a server
clock, a reference clock,
that you will have over the network.
And the client clock sends a message
asking what time it is,
server reads this time,
sends a response back.
In this later example,
the client can then have
all the information it needs
to adjust its time,
realize it's running two minutes beyond,
and will correct its
clock, and it's good to go.
But is it?
The reality is that the
frequency changes all the time.
You cannot ask what time is
it only once, and be done.
You have to continuously ask
what time is it repeatedly.
So this operation repeats,
and this communication of other network
then sees messages being exchanged
with certain various dealers,
and, of course, the risk of failure
when messages are dropped.
Alright, we talked about
clocks, how to fix them,
how to track the drift,
track drift and correct them.
So why is clocks synchronization
a hard problem still?
The short answer is that the
network is part of the problem.
This communication between
a clock to be adjusted
and your trusted friend
that can give you the accurate time,
is problematic for two reason.
First on on left-hand side
we show you an example.
The first reason is
that the viability in the
delays of communications
have an impact.
Here, the blue line shows you
the noise of the communication delays
when a server repeatedly
ask what time it's.
And the hard problem is
to identify this purple line here,
which is actually the cloud drift
from this very, very noisy blue input.
That's one key difficulty,
seeing through the noise,
seeing through the viability
of the communication delays.
The second problem that
happens with the network
is that the network is not symmetrical.
So far I've shown an example
where you can adjust your time,
you have an exchange
and as you can see on the top graph,
you have a nice triangle
that is very symmetrical.
Imagine now that these
two clocks are perfect.
Imagine that we have achieved
perfect synchronization.
On that first triangle
graph in here is great,
time is being exchanged,
two clocks are in agreement,
they're perfectly synchronized.
Second example, clocks are still perfect,
but the standard network
is not symmetrical.
When the client compares the time
from the server to its own time,
it'll observe a difference.
That difference is not the clock error,
we have assumed the clocks are perfect,
it's just a network asymmetry.
But from a client point
of view, it's ambiguous.
It cannot make a difference
between the clock error
and the network asymmetry.
All right, so this is a
very fast-tracked view
about what the problem is.
And a few years ago we really
wanted to build good clocks
for the purpose of
synchronizing our cloud.
So we went through this analysis,
what clocks are,
how they're made, and what the primes are.
We knew the primes of tracking clock
based over a non-deterministic network
is not something any of our customers
wanted to have to worry about.
So we put ourself to work,
and I'm gonna let Josh take us there.
- So Julien just covered a lot
for 9:00 AM on a Wednesday,
or if you're watching this recording.
And, again, as he said,
the good news is you
don't need to know that.
We've done the work for you.
We started with the
Amazon Time Sync Service,
which was a NTP, network
time protocol endpoint,
a link local for every
EC2 instance worldwide.
We invested in engineering and hardware
to support this service globally,
and we did this in 2017 for our customers.
I wanna start by showing
you what that looks like.
So here's an EC2 instance.
You have the the Nitro system down below,
the instance up above,
chronyd or or your time
daemon in your software.
And what you have is a NTP packet
from our distribution system
through the Nitro system to your server
that you can use to correct your clock.
The accuracy for our NTP service
is under one millisecond.
It's really in the the 500
to 700 microsecond range.
And customers were happy.
This is easy.
It's hands off.
Again, you don't need to understand
the science, the
technology, the methodology
behind doing this.
It's handled for you,
but customers have asked for more.
And when you really wanna use
clocks in distributed systems,
you need to get much better
than one millisecond.
And we challenge ourselves,
how do you get to nanoseconds?
Other cloud providers and scalers
try to do this with software.
And there are different ways
that you could go through
with lucky packets,
and very clever algorithms
and designs to get close.
We found in testing you really
need to invest in hardware,
all the way down to the servers,
to get to nanoseconds.
And this is how we did it.
Here's an animation of what it looks like,
but we have dedicated cables from GPS
redundant atomic hardware clocks,
and we send a signal, a referenced signal,
essentially a GPS signal,
to your EC2 instances.
This is not over the EC2
network and the AWS network.
It's not over the data plane,
it's not over the control plane.
This is entirely dedicated
for clock synchronization.
And I wanna show what
that looks like, again,
at the instance, going deeper,
'cause this is a a 400-level talk
on what the infrastructure looks like,
'cause we really took the network
out of network time synchronization,
and everything's
hardware-based and Nitro-based.
It's a great story about
Nitro and the Nitro System.
So what does that look like?
You now see there's a Nitro
clock, hardware reference clock.
and if you're using NTP, your NTP packet,
the network time protocol,
does not go over the network,
it's just directly to
the Nitro card and back.
We've also added a PTP hardware clock
directly in the Nitro System.
And the way that that works for you,
is you read the the PTP
hardware clock, the PHC,
and you can correct the
system clock right there.
So as you see, there's
no network communication.
We give the PTP, the precision
time protocol, for you,
because that's what most
software and systems
are familiar with.
But as you can see, there is no backend,
there's no PTP distribution within AWS.
It's all local to a reference block.
That is how we get into
the microsecond and nanosecond range.
When you're using the Amazon
Time Sync Service this way,
NTP is gonna be under
a hundred microseconds
at the software level in your guest.
And then PTP is gonna be in the range
of around 20 microseconds,
again, in the software
layer at your guest.
And then just to to recap, this
is built on the Nitro System
where we've added these
reference PTP hardware clocks.
What's really cool about that
is we add them everywhere.
It could be built on
Graviton, on Intel, on AMD,
on our latest GPU servers as well,
because, again, the base is the
hardware of the Nitro System
and this large infrastructure investment
we're doing worldwide
to support this feature.
Now if you're paying close attention,
you might realize I
talked about nanoseconds,
but that in the software layer
you're in the microsecond range.
And our customers have
called us out on this too,
said, "Hey, if you have these
nanosecond reference blocks,
how do we get to nanoseconds as well?"
Julien, can we share how we go further
in getting to the nanoseconds?
- Thank you Josh.
Yes, we can definitely talk
about one of the key applications.
So far we went through
explaining or describing
what is a clock made of,
how to correct for it,
and the system we build at AWS
to have this level of accuracy in there.
One of the key application
that our customers were
really interested in
is the ability to do
hardware packet timestamping.
This is the feature we've
launched earlier this year,
and has a lot of benefit, first
of all from observability.
If you can timestamp
packet closer to the wire,
you get a more accurate view
about the network performance,
which is very important
if you are running a distributed workload.
Some application also are very interested
in hardware packet timestamping,
because it allows to order messages
that you're receiving in your server.
That facility is built
in in the ENA driver,
and so you can access it today readily.
It provides nanosecond
resolution on received timestamp
to your instance for
all the network packet
that your server is involved with.
How do you access this facility?
You can access this through
the classic circuit API
that most applications are built over,
or the DPDK toolkit
that allows to bypass
kernel infrastructure
and get access to the
packets going to the wire.
So with this facility
you get the benefit of
a very accurate clock,
and gain a lot of insight
into how your application
operates over the network.
This sounds a little bit abstract
so I want to take you through the example
of the before and the after.
Here on this slide
I'm going to illustrate how
would you do the same things
before this feature was released.
So we are first looking at the application
of timestamping packets
messages you receive
at the application layer.
Let me start with a simple animation.
Here we still have the Nitro System
that underpins our virtualization layers
and the instance that runs on top.
A message arrives, passes
through the Nitro System,
goes through your instance,
the application receive the packet,
reads the time from the system clock.
You now have a time stamp
attached to your message.
How much work does it take to do this?
Well on the right-hand side you can see
it takes about four lines
of C code in this example.
You open a socket.
Here I'm using the
socket AP as an example.
You receive the packet.
Once you have received that
message you can read the time.
It's relatively simple.
Let me now show you how
you would do the same thing
by using the hardware packet
timestamping facilities.
Again, the Nitro System is here,
but now we have the natural
clock that Josh described prior.
Again, let's go through
a little animation.
Message arrives.
This time the package is timestamping
by the Nitro System and the Nitro clock
before it reaches your instances.
Then the message and the
timestamp created for you
is then passed to your
application, up to the layers.
On the right-hand side of the slide,
bit of an illustration
around how much work does it take.
Well, a little bit more.
You can see the number of
lines of code has increased.
You still need to create a socket,
you still need to receive a message,
but you have to do a little bit more work
to process control information,
extract the timestamp that's
been creating for you.
Nothing catastrophic, but
just a little bit more work.
Now, what do you get
from doing this extra
piece of work in here
and to access the timestamp
that are created by the Nitro System?
So here we have a little illustration,
we have two instances pinging each other
across an availability zone,
and we're recording the round-trip time
of this exchanges.
We have two graphs, two
lines on this graph,
but they are actually
measuring the exact same thing.
They are both measuring
the round-trip time
between these two instances.
The line at the top, in blue,
is if you measure this round-trip time
using userspace in your application,
the first example, the before.
As you can see, we're in the range
of 400 microseconds of round-trip time
between these two instances.
The red line is measuring
the exact same thing,
but this time using the
hardware packet timestamping
offered by the Nitro system.
And this time we're in the range
of about 100, 150 microsecond
of round-trip time measure.
We measure the same thing,
but our yard stick is much
more accurate and much precise.
The difference between these two lines
is around 250 microsecond in that example.
And this is the amount of time they spent
into your operating
system, the network stack,
and passing this information
to the user space.
If you look at this example,
this represent about two
thirds of the round-trip time,
that is actually the time
spent over the network.
So you get a much more accurate
view of what's going on.
The observability of
the network performance
is becoming much crisper.
It can start identifying and breaking down
what are the delays
between your application and the network.
Alright, I'm gonna pass
that back to Josh now.
Thank you very much.
- Thanks Julien.
With this technology
we wanted to give examples
of why this matters
and how this is used.
I'm very happy to introduce Nikolai,
the Senior Vice President
of Cloud Strategy and Enterprise
Architecture at Nasdaq
to show how they are
leveraging precision time
with the Amazon Time Sync Service.
- Thank you, Josh.
Thank you, Julien.
So building on all of that
excellent background of work,
we're gonna walk you through a little bit
about just background on who Nasdaq is,
but how we're using this technology
to demonstrate progress towards our goals
of running markets in public cloud.
So first a little bit of background.
Nasdaq is an innovator.
We were the world's
first electronic exchange
created in 1971.
We operate more than 30
markets around the world,
in the US and Nordics that covers stocks,
bonds, and options, and other derivatives.
We are known as the
home of technology stock
and technology stocks globally.
And we host the top four
companies by market cap,
of course including Amazon,
Who were are proud to
have as a listed company.
We also provide technology
to more than 130 market operators.
So exchanges, clearing houses,
regulators around the globe,
and provide technology
to more than 2300 financial institutions.
That could be from managing surveillance,
anti-financial crime or capital flows,
reporting, number of other things,
and more than 6,000 corporates.
We provide technology
to support their journey
in both private and public markets
through the full life
cycle of capital markets.
We have a listing venue,
and we have approximately
4,400 public companies listed
on Nasdaq exchanges globally.
Now, we have been an innovator in cloud,
and we started our cloud journey
well over 10 years ago now,
I think probably close
to 15 at this point.
But we'd had approached it very carefully
and very thoughtfully.
And so what you see here
is a kind of representation
of we started from the edge out,
we started with our data
repositories, data warehousing.
So we had our first data warehouse
in 2012, 2013-ish,
created natively in AWS using Redshift.
We've continued to evolve that.
We now store about 60 petabytes of data
in that data warehouse.
And that underpins a
number of key functions,
mostly back office in this case,
that support the operation
of our exchanges,
including billing and
regulatory reporting.
But we didn't stop there.
We continued our journey
into more and more real-time processing.
Started with things like
our market surveillance,
taking streaming real-time
market information
to perform that.
Market data distribution is now available
through public cloud.
You can subscribe to Nasdaq products,
and a number of alternative data sets.
And of course in 2022 we
announced, and we launched,
our first options exchange on AWS Outpost,
Nasdaq MRX.
And we've continued that cadence,
and we now have six-plus market systems
running on Outpost.
We continue that journey.
In addition, a number of our
critical surrounding systems
that provide real time
insight to market participants
on the trading activity that's
occurring on the market.
Those are hosted natively
in the public cloud
and we take advantage of the scalability
and the performance that are right-sizing
to process the large volumes
of messages we handle,
and the peaks managed capacity.
So of course we do have
some specific challenges
in moving to the cloud.
One of those is that the,
in particular in the US
there's a very specific geography
in which trading occurs,
and that's predominantly
in northern New Jersey
for equities and equity options.
So that provides some constraints
on where you can deploy the compute,
because there's latency
dependencies between those exchanges
that are all hosted in that general area.
We also have ultra-low
latency transactions.
And by that I mean something on the order
of 20 microseconds measured
as what we call order to act.
So that's the time and
order comes into our system,
gets processed, booked in to match,
potentially trades, and
return to the customer.
And coming with that, we
also have large volumes,
well north of a hundred
billion messages day currently,
with any specific exchange system
processing up to two to three
million messages a second.
We also have high resiliency
in uptime expectations.
The capital markets depend on us.
We are a primary listing venue
for a number of public
companies, as mentioned earlier.
And us being there to
provide that liquidity,
provide that venue for people to trade
and generate price
discovery is a key function
of how we keep our
capital market sufficient
and operating well.
And of course, we do
have regulatory oversight
of what we do,
where we run things, how we run things,
and what third parties
we're interacting with.
So we put all these together,
and I think you start to see the picture
of why we've been a very intentional
over the past 10 to 15 years,
continuing to move progressively
to more and more real time
and into the match.
Okay, so now we're running these exchanges
on Outpost,
and many of the supporting
systems in public region.
But we don't wanna stop there.
So this is where Amazon
Time Sync comes in,
and I wanted to talk through
some of the prototyping and
experimentation we've been doing
to demonstrate some of the capabilities
that will enable us to deploy
markets into the public cloud.
But first, a short primer
on an exchange system.
So a very high-level architecture view
of an exchange trading system.
There's really three primary components.
Before I go there,
should mention that we operate
three equities exchanges
and six options exchanges in the US.
And as mentioned before,
more than 100 billion messages a day,
with a single exchange out of
those six options exchanges
running north of 30
billion messages a day.
And as mentioned,
the median latency is about
20 microseconds for that.
So if we look at the
components of the system here,
we have of course at the
top left, as you can see,
the matching engine.
And that is where the primary logic
to book orders and trades,
and match buyers and sellers,
and generate trades occurs.
Going one level down,
we have what we refer to as order ports,
and those are the primary point
of interface for customers
who are sending order
flow to our exchange,
and act as the point of validation,
and in some cases pre-trade risk
and other functions occur there.
Next to that, on the right,
we have our, what we call
our public market data feeds.
So this is a published view
of what's happening in the
matching engine to the market,
Nasdaq ITCH, for those
of you familiar with it.
And then of course at the bottom,
but maybe the driver for the whole thing,
are the clients that
provide the order flow
to the order ports, to
the matching engine,
through their inbound transactions
from a round trip through the system.
So with that background,
an exchange trading system
on-prem is a traditional model.
It's a model we run today,
and most other exchanges in the world.
You wanna provide a deterministic
and statistically fair
market to participants.
And so how do we accomplish that?
Well, given that it's an
on-premise data center,
there's certain physical
characteristics we can rely upon.
That is the lengths of
fibers in the data center,
the number of switch hops
between components of
the system and customers.
And those drive what you
see here as D1 and D2,
the primary sources of
network latency in the system.
And then D3 encompassing
both the network components
and the processing components.
D3 being one half of the round trip.
So you can think of that as
about roughly 10 microseconds.
So because of those
physical characteristics
and the sequential processing
of the matching engine,
you result in an orderly
processing of orders
that are processed as they're
submitted by customers
and returned to customers
and public market data feed
in a consistent and
repeatable time period.
So that doesn't work so well
when you're talking about
public cloud, obviously.
We definitely do not
have fixed cable lengths.
We definitely often don't
have any idea really
how many switch hops sit between nodes,
and there can be various other things
happening in the network.
There can be other traffic
that's delaying packets,
or just the placement of
compute nodes can be, you know,
it can be unpredictably from
even within the data center
can be on one side or the other
or it could be in across AZs,
or it could even be across
regions potentially.
So what do you do about that?
Given that we, you know, again,
focus on these three kind
of key time periods here,
so D1, D2, and D3.
This is where the timestamps come in.
So using hardware timestamps
to record the time of each transaction
at each point through the network.
We can then use this high-precision
distributed time source
to understand when orders
came into the system
or were sent by customers,
and hence then when we should process them
to ensure the sequential processing
and sequential distribution
of those messages.
So if you look here at
the kind of key components
that we have that are relevant, right,
so we have our RBs, or
reordering buffer at the top left
sitting in front of the matching engine.
And it's important to note that
this POC is really focusing,
and what we're discussing here,
is focusing on the ordering
of inbound transactions.
Now there's obviously a
similar problem domain for,
or a network flow going
the other direction.
Similar techniques apply,
and I think you can use your imagination
to see how that would expand.
But that's not the specific
focus of this POC that we did.
But using that reordering buffer
and the hardware timestamps
that are provided through Nitro
and through the Time Sync Service,
we are now now able to
determine, for example,
T1 being the time of
an order being received
at the order port from client one,
T2 being the time an order was received
at the order port from client two,
and T3 being the time of an order received
from client three.
Given that those are hardware timestamps
with nanosecond precision,
we can use that information to
define a time-based boundary,
and using the reordering buffer
that understands those timestamps
to put them back in the,
or ensure that they're in the order
that they originated from.
Now this is obviously
a specific challenge,
and we'll talk just a little
bit more about what that means.
So how they're used, right,
so if you think back to
the prior slide with,
excuse me, with the T1, T2, T3,
in this case we have on
the inbound side order T1
flushed at time T1,
or received, I should say, at time T1,
gets flushed at time T11.
So we have T1 and at
time T3 we have order T3,
and T4 we have order T2.
As a result of the reordering,
on the outbound side
we see it as order T1,
order T2, and order T3,
reordered to their originating timestamp.
So this is a clear,
and we have a patent for this technique
to use time for this.
This is something we've been working on
for a number of years,
and we see as foundational
to continue to evolve
our posture towards public cloud
for these kinds of very
sensitive, low-latency systems.
So what did we do this with?
So if I go back to the prior slides.
So just thinking about the prototype
that we built with this.
So we're running on AWS public instances
using those r7i.2xls,
using proximity placement groups
to ensure that the compute nodes
were placed close in
relation to each other
within a few racks, or
within the same rack.
And then using these hardware timestamps
to reorder those packets.
So what we have here, if
you look at this example
and you take these timestamps,
and we, in our testing example,
we used two time boundaries
to demonstrate the impact of this.
One was a five-microsecond boundary.
And at five microseconds,
as you might imagine,
you're not successful in
reordering all that many packets,
because that's probably more,
you will take many packets
much longer than that
to arrive at the matching engine.
So they fall outside
the reordering boundary.
But that's about,
let's say roughly that
was about 25% of packets
got reordered successfully
in that time boundary.
When we move it up to 50 microseconds,
we see, depending on the message rate,
84% or higher, right?
So we continue to iterate on that boundary
work on how we can continue
to evolve the proximity
placement functions
so that we can get greater granularity
of where to place them,
and leveraging the
Amazon Time Sync Service
to accomplish that.
So if we look forward
with this foundation,
and as I mentioned earlier,
this is a key part of our innovation,
and working with AWS to solve problems
that are hard for public cloud,
as we believe that many of
these problems will be solved
or will get migrated to
the cloud in the future.
We wanna be part of that solution.
So this is about, for us
a developing scalable trading systems,
continuing to ensure that our systems
are the most scalable
and performant systems
wherever they are deployed,
if that's in public cloud or on premise.
We know there's a lot of innovation
happening in public cloud,
and certain things like
the explosion of AI,
and how we're gonna apply that.
And certainly, you know,
bringing our data to public cloud
is a key part of that strategy
enhancing our security and reliability.
So as mentioned before,
we have high expectations
both from ourselves,
and from our clients,
and from the regulators in
terms of being available
and ensuring that the capital
markets continue to flow.
And public cloud
has significant advantages
in both of those
in that, you know, you
do have to understand
the resiliency considerations,
and make sure that you're
building with those in mind.
They're not the same as on-prem,
but built responsibly
and in the right way,
they're much more resilient and secure.
And of course, the final part point there
is that leveraging our
strategic market expertise,
are, you know, operation
of 30 exchanges globally,
and as a supplier to 130
marketplaces around the world,
we are a leader,
we need to think strategically about this,
and how we apply technology to this.
So thank you.
Thanks for the time to Josh and Julien
for the Time Sync work,
and we look forward to
future innovation here.
- Thanks.
Thanks Nikolai.
I love that example in technical depth,
and we get really deep
into the hardware world
and hardware timestamps.
But most people are not
building a financial exchange
like Nasdaq.
And we wanna get into how you
leverage really good clocks
in your systems globally, and at scale,
and back into the software world.
I'm going back to this
quote from Barbara Liskov
on distributed systems and
reducing communication,
'cause we now have a very good clock
in the nanosecond range,
where in the software world
you're in microsecond range.
And we have the hardware
packet timestamping.
This allows your
applications to be better.
You can measure your network latency.
You have monitoring and observability
in the micro- and nanosecond scale
and consistent point-in-time snapshots.
But we still haven't talked
about distributed systems.
And distributed systems
are all about ordering.
Distributed systems have multiple clocks,
that's why it's a distributed system.
So in the first example on the left,
if you have a system with
one clock and three events,
it's relatively easy to
know what event comes first.
But as Nikolai pointed out,
when you have multiple servers,
they each have their own clock,
and each clock is a little different.
And as that system scales,
it gets more complex.
In the past,
it's been difficult to rely on the clocks
'cause they were not
good enough to compare.
So things like distributed locks,
leader election consensus algorithms
built by decades of very
smart computer scientists,
Turing Award winners,
have been done to do
ordering on a complex system.
But these algorithms put
a limit onto performance.
And as the system grows larger,
so does that complexity.
In order to use a clock,
we recommend, you know,
changing the way you read a clock.
I look at, you know,
Julien's example asking a friend for time.
You ask, "What time is it?"
And we think, as humans, as
people, it's it's 2:00 PM.
But no clock is perfect, and
each clock has an uncertainty.
So if you're using our precision clocks
in the software layer,
when you say, "What time is it?"
you need to think about,
"Oh, it's 2:00 PM plus or
minus 20 microseconds."
And perfect time must be
within that uncertainty window.
And you have to factor
in a margin of error
in your software application.
I'm gonna go a little deeper into why,
and then Julien will
show how we simplify that
so that you could do it
without needing to
understand these details.
But I think it's important
to share these really deep details.
Here's a simplified
example of a bank account.
Let's say you're starting
with a balance of zero,
and there's two places where
there are transactions.
Maybe a deposit of $10
at the bank on node two,
that could be a direct
deposit, electronically,
and then a withdrawal.
Looking at those confidence intervals,
you know, that event
one, that first deposit,
occurred before the other
two with absolute certainty,
but processing the other
two is really important.
If you get the order wrong,
you might have an overdraft,
you might not have enough
money funds in your account
to withdraw.
So Julien, knowing this, how do do we,
how do customers know
what these intervals are?
- Well, that's actually a
fairly complex question,
and we thought we would
start by an example, right?
We know that no clock is perfect,
and so we need to estimate
the error of this clock
to build this window of uncertainty.
So let's start with this example here.
If you were to start an EC2 instance
with a default configuration,
you could inspect your
time synchronization then,
and to look at the sources it's using
to synchronize your own clock.
I'm gonna start from the
bottom of this output in here.
One row at a time.
The bottom line represents a source
that is over on the internet.
NTP servers on the internet,
for example, time.aws.com
will be a source of time here.
The second row from the bottom up
is accessing the local NTP servers
offered by the Nitro System
that Josh described before.
And last, the row at the top
represent the PTP hardware clock,
which is our Amazon Time
Sync Service in here
that is provided again
by the Nitro system.
What matters in this output?
Lots of numbers.
What matters in there is the
column on the right-hand side.
That is what the time
synchronization daemon believe
is the size of the window of uncertainty
that Josh was describing.
Again, from the bottom,
if you use an NTP source over
the internet in this example,
395 microsecond is the
width of that window.
If you use the local NTP sources,
it shrinks to 90 microsecond,
much better, much more accurate.
And lastly, if you use
the PTP hardware clock,
the time daemon here
announces 32 nanosecond
as the size of the window,
something quite small.
But the reality is that there's
a little bit more to it.
And we, Josh, myself,
and the team behind the Amazon
Time Sync Service knows that,
we have engineered the
system from the ground up.
It turns out there's a
little bit more to know
behind this number than
just what is printed out
in this output.
And I want to give you a bit
more information and details
about what that is.
But the reality is that
getting this information
is extremely complex,
and we cannot ask any of our customer
to know the details beyond
the engineering and the setup,
the infrastructure that
we have put in place.
So to solve that question,
to answer that question,
simply since 2021, we
have released a software,
infrastructure software
demo called ClockBound.
It's open source,
and it's available on GitHub,
at the URL printed in here on the slide.
The key information about this software
is that it gives you
the answers in one call.
In a single operation,
you get three pieces of information.
First you get the current time,
it's Monday, 2:00 pm.
Second you get the size of that window,
plus minus 20 microsecond.
And last,
because it's important to
every single application,
you get a status about
the validity of the clock.
Is it initialized?
Is it free-running?
Is it synchronized?
So in one call, you get these
three pieces of information,
which gives you much richer information
about time and the clock status,
and the quality of times
upon which you can build
your own business logic.
The ClockBound demo has been supporting
PDP hardware clock sources and
NTP sources from the get-go.
It scales to the most demanding workload.
You can ask this question
millions of time per second
to make sure that we can match workload
such as the one that Nikolai
was describing before.
It is a piece of software
that is written in Rust,
something we like in Amazon
for performance and memory safety.
We really care about this concept.
It's available in Rust as a client
and also for your C application
if you want to back-port it.
Now I want to give you
a bit of an intuition
about the calculation behind the scene.
Again, you do not need
to know these details,
ClockBound, solve this problem for you.
However, it's nice to
have a bit of an intuition
about what this is all about.
If I were to summarize what
the Clock Error Bound is
in one sentence,
this would be the tightest bound
on the worst case clock error
that is due to either oscillator drift
and communication delays.
And this illustration
one the right-hand side
gives you a sense for
how errors accumulate.
At the bottom of the stack,
we have the Amazon Time Sync Service,
with all the infrastructure
that Josh described before.
GNSS antennas, atomic clock.
We get into the nanosecond
range of accuracy in hardware.
But of course this information
has to be passed up the stack
through layers of operating
system and your application.
And this is where some
little errors do accumulate.
When you target nanosecond
and microsecond level,
everything does matter.
And so as you move up the stack,
you move from nanosecond accuracy
up to microsecond accuracy,
and this is where chronyd
shine and give you the answer.
Now again, giving you some
intuitions about this,
let's imagine that you have
studied an EC2 instance
that you're running the
ClockBound demo and the client.
You can inspect it and ask
what is the value and the size
of this uncertainty window
at any point in time.
So in this example in here,
the white dotted line
represents an hypothetical
perfect synchronization,
the perfect clock.
And as you can see, over time
the size of the window grows and shrinks.
It grows linearly,
and shrinks when the clock
is updated on every tick,
and grows again.
At any point in time you can ask
what is the size of the window,
which is represented
here but this interval
between the earliest and the
latest borders boundaries
of that uncertainty window.
So with ClockBound,
the result is that all this complexity
is handled for you, right?
And you will get this result
and be able to access it as
from here in this diagram.
Now with ClockBound,
we now have a tool that
allows applications
and customer application
to leverage their local
time with confidence.
And some applications are
particularly interested
in this new functionality
and Josh is going to tell us all about it.
- Thanks, Julien.
Now's the fun part.
Getting into who is using
this, and how they're using it.
Again, doing all of the
difficult communications for you,
we have the primitive of the
precision time, the hardware,
the hardware timestamps,
and then ClockBound doing that work
to reduce the communications
that we talked about
in the quote at the start
of the presentation.
The first example I wanted to share
is yugabyteGB.
Yugabyte is an open-source database
using our open source ClockBound software.
And they have a system called
a Hybrid Logical Clock.
They do some of the ordering,
you know, logically,
as a traditional database would
combined with our precision clocks.
And when leveraging the
Amazon Time Sync Service
in ClockBound,
the first thing that they
saw was reduced latency
for their customers by three times.
They also saw
increased throughput in
the transactions doubles.
And then the big number
I wanna share and focus on is incredible,
a thousand times fewer retries.
A retry would typically occur
when you have two transactions,
let's say a read and a
write at the same time,
and there's a conflict.
And these retries, it's
additional communication,
it's load on on their
network communications,
it's load on their servers
that no longer exists.
The result is a better experience
for their customers in consistency,
you know, isolation,
but also just end user
experience in their database.
Have a QR code there of a blog
I co-wrote with Karthik,
co-founder and co-CEO of yugabyte,
if you wanna learn more about
their Hybrid Logical Clocks,
and see some examples of this.
At AWS we are also using our
precision clocks at scale.
We're doing that with Aurora DSQL
and with DynamoDB Global Tables.
These are both multi-region
global planetary scale databases.
The reason why it's shown
in this diagram here.
So these are network
latencies in milliseconds
across three regions in the US.
So if you look at us-west-2 to us-east-1,
you're gonna have a latency
of around 70 milliseconds.
And again, we're talking about clocks
in microseconds in nanosecond range.
So using our precision clocks,
you know faster than sending
a packet over the network,
the order of your transactions.
And this is what it looks
like with Aurora DSQL.
This is the same example,
the same diagram I showed you earlier
with the bank accounts,
getting a little deeper
and more complicated.
And this time we're looking at two nodes
from two different
regions for Aurora DSQL.
And getting this right
is critical for consistency in isolation
in a multi-region database.
Using ClockBound's uncertainty window,
you have event one with
a T start and T commit
which is guaranteed to be in the past,
compared to event two or event three.
Now, event two and three, as you can see,
have some overlap,
and they need to be processed carefully.
One thing you can do is delay an event.
So delay the T start of event three,
so there's no retry.
If let's say that was a read,
and event two was a write.
But again, it depends on your
database or system design,
the type of events that are occurring,
and what you want for your customers.
But this is not a database talk,
I'm not gonna go further into that.
It could take hours.
Here are three sessions going
deep into the architecture
of Aurora DSQL and Aurora DynamoDB.
These are all later this week.
And for people listening
in on the recording,
these are also all recorded sessions
that you can find online.
Now, we've covered a lot.
We've gone very deep
into the science of time.
We have Nasdaq's example on
leveraging hardware timestamps
for in-region financial exchanges.
We've talked about thinking,
and changing the way
that you think about time
in measuring not just a specific time,
but in interval and confidence.
AWS partners and AWS
databases leveraging this.
But I promised you at the
beginning of this presentation
that while it's good to understand this,
you don't need to go that
deep to put this to you
to work in your systems.
So we have one more thing to
share with everyone today,
because customers ask us,
"These primitives are
incredible and very powerful,
but how do we make it easier to use?
How do we build our software in Systems
and have this this work done for us?"
Julien, do we have an answer?
- Well that's the part
where I'm probably going
to get a bit more excited.
So as we described,
we have built a very accurate
time synchronization service at Amazon.
We support many workload.
We support innovation.
We have example from Nasdaq,
innovation in the new
generation of databases.
The point of this
is that our customers
put their trust in us.
And so we have to continue
to keep that trust,
and continue to improve the
customer experience over time.
And that's why I'm very happy to announce
that we have just raised
a new AWS time daemon.
The thing is, it's under
the same software stack,
the same ClockBound software
that we have at least four years.
And it's still accessible on GitHub,
but this URL, the QR code
will take you there as well.
There are a lot of improvements
we have made in there.
A lot of work has been done in it
to continue to improve and
deliver higher accuracy
and higher reliability for our customers.
One of the key change, and key innovation
is that ClockBound now
includes this time daemon,
which is a standalone
time client and daemon.
It does not rely on
third-party software anymore.
It will synchronize your
operating system clock for you,
as well as continue to
give you this information
for your application to
know what time it is,
the size of the window of uncertainty,
and the status of the
clock, all in one go.
It's important for many reason.
Nikolai mentioned regulatory reason there,
but also just simple observability
for your distributed system.
We have built-in metrics.
Observability is a first-class citizen,
and must be absolutely
a first-class citizen.
Again is the same build on
same software stack in Rust
that is provide memory
safety and high performance
and performance is achieved
through different means.
Here we have a shared memory segment
that allows for interprocess communication
that allows us to provide this information
at a very high rate.
So this is very exciting,
and there are two more things
that I want to share with you
before going into more details
in the following slide.
The first one is that we
have redesigned the system
to be a cloud-first design.
Time synchronization software
has existed for decades
before the cloud existed.
Here we make a massive change in paradigm.
Most of the historical system
use a feedback-loop system
that is not well suited
to cloud application.
We've changed that around.
We now have a system
that feed forward
information in the system
which is much more friendly
to cloud application.
And we'll talk a bit more
about this in a second.
And last, if you're like us,
you are a time nerd in the room,
or watching this online,
I just want you to know
that the new software stack
ships with a simulator that
allows you to test the software,
see it for yourself,
find what you like in it,
potentially report some issues,
or things you would like to see improved.
And we will welcome your
feedback of course as you try it.
So let me go back quickly
into the last components
of the talk in here.
First we talk about
cloud-native synchronization.
So you know that at AWS
availability is a top priority
through all the layers of the utilization.
We made some innovation in here,
and contributed a new
feature to the Linux kernel
called VMClock, for virtual machine clock.
And this feature, combined
with our new ClockBound,
when it release,
allows the direct transfer of time
from the Nitro Clock into your instance.
It's an improvement over
any kind of maintenance
event to the point
that you now have your
workload rolling smoothly
at any point in time.
Great.
Let's have a quick look at how this looks,
as well in terms of performance.
Similar to the earlier slides,
top graph in here shows
the drift of an oscillator
in a banner, like
thousands of microsecond.
How well are we doing?
What result is the graph below?
Given this input,
we managed to track and
correct for the drift
to within the band of plus
or minus one microsecond
over this period of multiple hours.
This is how good the
system is working today.
So this is for the internal of the system,
but we mentioned that what matters
to the customer application
is the window of uncertainty.
So here we have a little application,
a little demonstration,
where we can see in real time
that we are constantly
querying the ClockBound daemon
to plot the size of the
window of uncertainty.
As you can see in the previous graph,
it has this saw-tooth behavior.
It grows and shrinks as
the clock gets updated.
But what matters in here
is that the result are in the band
of somewhere between
20 and 26 microsecond.
That's the size of the window
of certainty you can achieve
inside your application by
using this new application.
And now I see that we're almost at time,
and it's now a good opportunity
for Josh to conclude
and take us there.
- Thanks, everyone.
Now it's time for you to build
and take advantage of the
Amazon Time Sync Service
and the precision time
capabilities that we have.
Again, we've built this
into Amazon EC2 instances.
You could use AWS Databases, AWS Services
built to take advantage.
Using Nasdaq, AWS partners like yugabyte,
who are leveraging time for you.
Again, Amazon Time Sync and
ClockBound do the work for you,
and I can't wait to see
what you build using this.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)